if you're not being defined by a vision
of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so some
people will use their boss to reaffirm
their addiction to judgment they'll use
their enemy to reaffirm their addiction
to hatred they'll use their friends to
reaffirm their addiction to suffering so
now they need the outer world to feel
something so
to change then is to be greater than
your environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world and the
environment is that seductive
so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect from your outer
environment so if you're seeing less
things there's less stimulation going to
your brain if you're playing soft music
or you have ear plugs in less sensory
information coming to your brain so
you're disconnecting from your
environment we have a huge frontal lobe
and it's 40 of our entire brain
and most people
when they have a thought they just think
that that's the truth and i think one of
my greatest
realizations in my own journey was just
because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true so if you
think sixty to seventy thousand thoughts
in one day and we do and ninety percent
of those thoughts are the same thoughts
as the day before and you believe that
your thoughts have something to do with
your destiny your life's not gonna
change very much because the same
thought leads to the same choice the
same choice leads to the same behavior
the same behavior creates the same
experience and the same experience
produces the same emotion
and so then
the act of becoming conscious of this
process to
to begin to become more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition and so
then
why is that important because the more
conscious
you become of those unconscious states
of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought
is not going to slip by your awareness
unchecked
because you're
it means to know thyself and the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and the emotions
of the old self you're retiring that old
self as you fire and wire new thoughts
and condition the body into a new
emotional state if you do that enough
times it'll begin to become familiar to
you so
it's so important uh just like a garden
if you're planting a garden you got to
get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant a new garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because a person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
it turns out that when they're in their
life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change and
so we have to unlearn before we relearn
we have to break the habit of the old
self before we reinvent the new self we
have to prune synaptic connections and
sprout new connections we have to unfire
and unwire and re-fire and rewire we
have to unmemorize emotions that are
stored in the body then recondition the
body to a new mind into a new motion
like deprogram and reprogram that's the
act and it's a two-step process i had
this belief that i did not have an
abundant amount of money and
that i was always in struggle and that
came from my parents bless them you know
they are beautiful
um but that that came from them you know
we can't afford it and all of those
things so i was brought up with that as
many of us are so the one
one that i had the biggest thing to
overcome the belief the biggest thing to
overcome
was the belief in lack of money
and and i knew i needed to overcome that
for the secret to
sweep the world all the things i was
going to buy you know when the money
came in
um so i did all of these lists and i
imagined that i had those things already
um
and
yeah and i wanted i remember it was like
i want a house on the ocean i really
went all out you know that was just some
list um one of the things i remember is
that i'd always wanted a range for over
all of my life and that was just beyond
anything i could afford
and especially in australia like there
were crazy prices so but still i put it
on the list and i put all these things
on the list but you know interestingly
enough like i did that because that was
a way to turn money around
but when the secret got released i
didn't care about any of it because and
i didn't even care
all that mattered was that i had got it
out into the world and now it was in the
world it could never be taken away and
that is what mattered to me more than
anything is that that was going to get
into people's hands and so um but still
i have to tell you got all the things on
the list
you know it has amazing views out here
of the ocean
um i ended up by getting a range rover
um and so yeah but i did
i did a lot of practices i write in the
book about how
i'm gonna push the metaphysical envelope
and i'm going to go to places i haven't
gone before and i never went there
before because i didn't want to alienate
my reader and i had a lot of new seekers
that were joining me on this journey but
i feel right now that people are
completely ready for this conversation
and they can take it or leave it yeah
and make it their own yeah and my
beliefs do not have to be there so
that's a really important point that
whatever we believe when we think about
a higher power spiritual presence is
what we believe and all that matters is
that you believe it not that someone
said it's this or that it's it's it may
be a religious spiritual belief system
it may be a belief system from your
childhood maybe something that you read
in a book that resonated with you you
decide that's the beautiful thing about
being on a spiritual path but what i
share is what i believe to be true about
what it means to connect to the voice of
our higher self our inner guidance
system and our inner wisdom versus what
it means to rely on a guide or an angel
or a deceased family member
or a loved one and so i believe we all
have these two this t we all have a team
of of guides of spiritual guides that
work on our behalf all the time and what
they're there for is often to guide be a
bridge for our thoughts so when our
thoughts are in those low vibrations if
we pray to a guide or we pray to god or
we pray to an angel we can say thank you
for for bridging my thought from this
low vibrational fear-based belief system
to a higher vibe and the way that they
would do that may be by putting a book
in front of you or guiding you to an
episode of marietv that is going to just
change your mind so guides work through
the internet and books and people and
and and your and your subconscious and
so you're gonna maybe when you have
those moments where you're like i have
this sense that i need to to watch that
episode of marietv right now maybe
somebody watching just got the hit yeah
that could have been your guide just
giving you that boost of inspiration
watch that watch that because that's
going to change you and so don't
underestimate those moments of
synchronicity because there's support
that's leading you in those
synchronistic moments and so the more
that we align with our spiritual belief
systems and the more we
allow ourselves to accept that it's good
to feel good and the more we use things
like the emotional guidance scale or the
choose again method or any of the
methods in this book the better we feel
and the better we feel the more we can
hear the guidance that we're receiving
the guidance is always there but we
block it we cut it off and so we can
open up to that guidance research study
and psychology found out that both
second person and third person makes you
more
it makes yourself talk more powerful so
if you're going to do affirmations you
wouldn't just say i want to do this i
want to do this you want to do what we
call in the book self coaching where you
would say you know in my case yeah
brendan it's important you do a good job
here today because you usually don't do
interviews and you really love marie and
you want to do a good job for her and
her people
and this is a book you worked on for
three years and it's important it does
well and brendan don't forget
you're so lucky you get to do this
brother so just enjoy the process you're
so lucky brendan
that's a different level of going i'm
lucky i'm lucky right
it is i'm brendan yes yes another one
another one i do every morning yeah
assuming i take a shower but every
morning in the shower because we all
don't every day not every morning no we
do not this doesn't happen it does not
happen i told you like 24 hours ago i
was staying in a barn in the woods at a
friend's house yes um
but the second thing i asked myself in
the in the shower every morning is what
might happen today that could trip me up
and how are you going to bring your best
self to that brendan
i say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate you know something's going to
go wrong during the day absolutely and
if i already know everything like like
this morning's was okay
you're in
i think what we would i think i'm yes
north manhattan where i'm staying would
you call it north you're uptown i'm
uptown and you're coming to um let's
just call it downtown okay so i'm like
okay that's gonna be
45 minutes it's a hot summer day yes
i'm gonna get hot and i know when i'm
hot sometimes i get impatient yes and i
get stressed and i don't want to feel
that so just pay attention to how you're
feeling on your way down to the
interview with marie brendan
and really just engage pay attention be
present with new york and really enjoy
that you're here i know that sounds
completely crazy but every high
performing athlete does it every
salesperson does it i mean at high level
every person i interviewed who are at
what we call the top 15 of all high
performers
they all self-talk and most of them we
found we're doing it in second and third
person
which is amazing i love it yeah i think
it's so fun yeah little things yeah so
if you already talk to yourself and you
say your name to yourself
they're not crazy you're probably high
performing i think most of us
the biggest problem i think especially
today
is that we are so afraid of money
and so as much as we want money we are
so scared of it so uh why do you say
that i think that that hit me is very
counterintuitive why why do you think
people are scared of money it's because
of a money trauma i call it money wounds
that we we've had
since our childhood we used to have some
uh unless your parents are perfect and
unfortunately it's not the case in in
any any culture
so we've been scolded about money you
know we spent too much we wasted the
money or we denied a corrective lesson
or soccer lesson or a ballet lesson or
piano lessons because it's expensive
some of my friends were taught you are
not worth it well that's like that's a
big blow so
we've been denied so many times around
money so that's why as much as we want
money because we feel
uh money can buy happiness so money
money can buy at least freedom but at
the same times money
have been abused abused us for so many
ways so as much as we want to get close
to it but if we get too close to it we
get burns or like hurt so
for a lot of people money is a mystery
person
so how do they begin to change that
relationship i'm assuming some of this
is going to be just narrative around how
they talk to themselves about money what
do you advise people you have to start
watching your your language uh my mother
used to say that
and then uh around money especially
a lot of people say like you know i was
ripped off so there are so many negative
uh language around money
and
my mentor has said you have to use
positive words around money otherwise
money will not like you and i really i
thought it's very cute you know and then
uh
in my book i talk about
what if uh if if money were a person who
would it be like is that a person a
gentle person or hungry person so just
um you know
you have to pay attention to how you
relate to money uh if you just um
feel like money is just a thing like you
don't care but if you don't care
you know you end up being in debt so you
have to be very careful and respectful
for money
you don't have to stay stuck
when you come up with a great idea that
in your heart you know this is the thing
that i want to do and then almost
instantly all the negative voices come
in your head as to why you can't do it
and why someone like you will never be
able to do this thing
it keeps you stuck keeps you small keeps
you frustrated keeps you knowing that
you're capable of more and being too
afraid to go take the action
and until you can break that pattern of
negative self-talk
[Music]
nothing will happen and so we're gonna
fix that in this video i think as soon
as we come up with ideas
it's not even our friends it's not even
the people around us it's us it's it's
us telling ourselves that we suck that
we can't do it that we're not good
enough that we're not keepable that it's
not gonna happen
[Music]
we'd land into
procrastination mode
and you can call yourself a
perfectionist it has to be perfect
but perfectionism is still just fear
just fear just fear that you're not good
enough feel that it won't work out fear
of being seen fear of not being seen
and it keeps you stuck
when i procrastinate on things
even like making videos
yeah i've made i don't know how many 12
000 13 000 14 000 videos some crazy
number of videos and yet every time
before i sit down to make the videos i
procrastinate a little bit in today's
filming session
i'm here at my wife's acupuncture clinic
she's inside getting her acupuncture
done i joined her sitting in the car
and it probably took me
15 minutes
to get into
the zone i know i'm going to make the
videos i've developed the identity that
i'm going to get get it done but i'm i'm
worried i want i want the videos to be
good i wanted i
don't want to embarrass myself don't
want to let myself down don't want to
let you down fear of disappointing
people is my my biggest fear i don't
want you to feel like this is wasting
your time you ever had these thoughts
you know like you want to do something
and then you want it to be good and you
don't want to disappoint people and so
you ham when you ha and you
procrastinate and then and then all of a
sudden the day is gone you haven't done
anything you know how's that happen so i
try to keep it to 10 minutes 15 minutes
today's a little longer i'd usually be
like 5-10 minutes took a little bit
longer 15 minutes today to to get into
to get into the zone and you know what
happened the next thought was
uh what if i just check uh check and see
how my team is doing and and
because i want to feel valuable and
because i want to feel like i'm doing
something productive i want to get out
of the discomfort of not filming videos
and go check in on my team because that
would make me feel more productive like
no no no
just sit with it
we gotta we gotta change it we gotta go
we gotta make some content you're gonna
do this and make that first video so
even for me even for someone who's done
[Music]
five figures of videos
every time i sit in front of the camera
to make a video
the first one i procrastinate i sit on
it because i'm afraid
and i don't want to disappoint people so
it's totally normal
so if you feel like whatever the thing
is that you want to do
you know you're capable of it you know
in your heart that it's something that
you want to create
and then for some reason you keep
stopping you keep procrastinating you
keep staying stuck
that's normal
you're not
there's nothing wrong with you it's not
abnormal it's 100 everybody goes through
it
the difference is how quickly can you
shift how can you get unstuck
because most people just stay stuck they
stay constipated
like all this all the stuff that has to
come out that's just not coming out
you're constipated
you stay stuck so how do you do it how
do you shift it here are a couple things
that help me that i hope can help you
number one is is floss the first tooth
take immediate momentum you think about
flossing
it's you know people don't want to floss
i mean i floss i built a habit of
flossing twice a day
most people don't floss
and the concept is just floss one tooth
and once you floss one tooth you'll
floss the rest probably right just get
your running shoes on and go for a walk
and once you're walking you probably do
more than you know the two minutes that
you set yourself in the mind like just
do two minutes so for me
is just make the first video
come on evan just record the first video
so i recorded the first video and now
this is my second video in my filming
session and i'm already feeling better
it's like we're going we're vibing yeah
let's do this is amazing
come on
just get going just just go it's so much
easier to keep the momentum going once
you've built some momentum the hardest
step is the first step the hardest step
is just building that initial momentum
at the beginning once you get going it's
a lot easier to keep going so just start
don't don't make it some big thing
they'll make it some giant endeavor that
you have to go off and chase it's nice
to have big goals and big ambitions and
big dreams
but sometimes they're too big
and then you feel like you can't do it
and you need venture capital and you
need a team and you need all sorts of
things before you can do anything on it
it's great to have that big goal and
what are you gonna do today
to build some kind of momentum
and once you start building that
momentum it's just so much so much so
much so much easier so the challenge for
today is just just find one small simple
easy way to get started
it doesn't have to be amazing it doesn't
have to be great it's just the first
step
once you get your first step it's so
much easier to take the second so that's
one just start building some immediate
momentum number two is change your state
one of the reasons why i like filming in
the car people ask why are you always
filming in your car i like i like being
out i like i like being out of the place
out of my home i like i like energy i
like nature let me see trees and and
sunshine and have people around you know
i like i like that it changes my state
it's it makes it a lot easier for me
to go off and film when i'm by myself so
it's not just
um
me talking to the camera if this feels
more conversational i don't know it's
all it's all just uh a head game
but it feels more i feel like i'm
talking to a friend hello
how you doing i'm evan
it feels
it feels more conversational and natural
for me i like having the sun on my face
you know it just feels better and so
changing your state can be a good way if
you're in a
wherever you're at you know think
whether you're in your bed or in your
car or in your office or the dining room
table you know change your state move
around get up
you want to change the negative thoughts
start moving get up doesn't have to go
work out or do you know 100 jumping
jacks just get up and even get in some
fresh air getting out of the space
that you're thinking negatively in
really helps just changing your physical
location really really really really
helps i promise you
have you ever had a
you're thinking really negatively
um you're procrastinating you're feeling
down and then you go for a walk and you
feel better or even just change your
room
or you go to a different part of the
house or you go for a drive and then you
feel better like changing the physical
environment can really help you
get out of that funk that you're in
where while you're in that space you're
feeling
stuck and you can't move
so change the physical environment one
little bonus for that is music music i
should have done that today
music is
the fastest way to change your state
so while i was sitting here in the car
for 15 minutes procrastinating and
making these videos
instead of thinking hey i should go
and check in on my team and see how
they're doing underneath like logically
that makes sense like how's my team
doing i'm being a good boss you know
good manager
a good friend i should check in on them
see how they're doing it's going to move
my goals forward of course because if
they're waiting on me for something
right logically all that makes sense
underneath it is just
again the fear that
my videos won't be good enough so i need
to feel productive i need to feel value
valuable to myself i need to feel worthy
so i'm going to spend my time there
instead of making videos right
i should have put on music when that was
happening
instead of going to check out my team
which i didn't do but wanted to
uh i should have put on some music
like put on some music that makes you
move and you don't have to be the most
expressive dancer or singer just
anything that would get your head
bobbing or your foot tapping or your
knee bouncing just songs that make you
come alive and there's no one perfect
song but whatever song
gets you in the zone
even if you're feeling really low you'll
find yourself like having energy and
moving and it changes your state the
whole point is just to get unstuck and
to start building some momentum towards
what you say is what you want to do
right so music is the fast way to change
your state and then number three is i
would say have play bigger triggers
and play bigger triggers are the things
in your environment that remind you of
who you want to be
the things that you could put up the the
the reminders on your cell phone
background on your desktop background
the artwork on your wall
the things that you could put in your
life to remind you of who you want to be
so i'll share a couple from my example
in my office i have five pictures on the
wall and they all tell a different story
remind me of who i want to be i've got
steve jobs on the wall who reminds me to
be a visionary i've got ap giannini on
the wall who's my favorite entrepreneur
of all time and he reminds me to to
believe in
um in the little guy and what i'm trying
to do i've got my parents on the wall
who remind me to believe in myself i've
got howard schultz on the wall who
reminds me to stand for something
important i've got kanye on the wall to
remind me that the time is now that i
have to go do something now to be
the greatest me and
[Music]
those pictures i picked with intention
and when i walk into my office they're
there and they remind me
and i don't have to do anything you know
you set it up once and it reminds me it
reminds you of who you want to be i walk
in the office there's my parents looking
back at me and telling me to believe in
myself
the clothes that you wear right i wear i
wear this is my believe hoodie i feel
like i'm batman i tell myself when i put
this on i'm batman i'm a superhero going
to work
fighting
the crime of lack of belief
right and and so just somebody commented
on my hoodie yesterday's like you're
always wearing you're always on brand
you're always wearing your hoodie it's
like it's not just
it's not just when i show up to make
videos this is this is this is what i
wear because i'm a
i'm a superhero going to work
and when i put this on in the morning
it's like i'm i'm i'm batman going to
work or uh
you know police officer going to work
it's like this is this is what i do
and
i'm a lot more
for me
productive and ambitious and bold
when i'm wearing this compared to when
i'm in my pajamas
until there's a conscious choice i say
okay what do i want to wear
and so the artwork on my wall the
background on my cell phone the computer
screen background the
the
things that i wear right play bigger
triggers
that you ideally just set it up once
and then it reminds you it's okay there
it is there's my trigger again there
there it is this is who i want to be
this is who i want to be this is who i
want to be i'm around the things that
make me
remember what i'm trying to do because
your brain will trick you
to stay small your brain will trick you
to stay stuck your brain will trick you
to say
yeah you you can't do that and here's
all the reasons why
and you believe those reasons you
believe those reasons we're really
you're just afraid i'm just afraid i'm
afraid that we're not good enough we're
afraid that we're going to be judged
we're afraid of disappointing people
we're afraid of not being loved we're
afraid
that
we're going to be seen and going to be
made fun of you know we're just afraid
at the end of the day you me everybody
were just we're just afraid that the
reason why you're stuck is you're afraid
and so when you can learn
to catch those feelings
and when you can learn to uncover those
feelings and switch them so you know
what
i'm going to change my environment i'm
going to change my state i'm going to
change what i'm listening to i'm going
to change what i'm wearing i'm going to
change my mind and i'm going to go do
the thing to start building momentum
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum the only thing you're missing
is momentum you've got a great heart a
great soul a great idea your idea is
worthy you're doing it for the right
reasons you want to serve you can do
this you can be in a totally different
place in six months and 12 months you
can it's possible you can your mission
is worthy and noble and should happen
and you're the one to do it you you're
the one to do it
and it's not that you're not good enough
and it's not that you're not capable and
it's not that you can't do it at some
point you just don't have the momentum
momentum
you're just missing momentum
and so the next time you feel stuck
procrastinating not good enough
know that you can do it
and that all you need to do is take that
first step what's the number one reason
we procrastinate
is it because we want to
have you ever heard of the law of
secondary gain so think about this for
just a minute when you procrastinate
is there a benefit
when you procrastinate is there a
benefit think of a secondary benefit
is it possible pay close attention is it
possible that when we procrastinate
maybe
we're protecting ourselves
have you ever thought about that
when i procrastinate maybe i'm
protecting myself and so the question is
protecting myself from what
when i procrastinate maybe
i'm not doing what i need to do or want
to do i get that but maybe i'm also
protecting myself the question is
protecting myself from what
right so think about this let me let me
put a little meat around the bone for
you okay
when we procrastinate a secondary
benefit
could be
that we are fearful of let's say being
embarrassed i'll give you a couple of
examples so if i take the action that i
need to take or want to take whether
it's asking for a raise whether it's
leaving my job and trying to find
something new leaving a relationship i'm
not happy in um uh going across the room
and asking a man or a woman what their
name is um uh
starting you know a new career
doing something sometimes has
known and unknown consequences
associated with it so
if we are afraid that if we take action
and the action doesn't result
in the desired outcome that we want
is it possible
that the fear of failing or the fear of
disappointing yourself or the fear of
being embarrassed or the fear of being
ashamed or the fear of being ridiculed
or the fear of disappointing yourself
one more time or the fear of losing
money
is it possible that when your
subconscious mind okay is processing the
potential consequences
of the behavior
is it possible that as a protective
mechanism
we procrastinate is it possible that
hold on our 100 billion dollar bio
computer
100 billion by computer what i call is
the
frankenstein's monster part of the brain
right is it possible
that that part of the brain is causing
the behavior we call procrastination
right so is it possible that
procrastination
is
in many cases
a secondary gain mechanism
to protect us
so we want to do what we want to do the
behavior but our brain is always
processing what is the potential
negative consequence
now or in the future and if
we deem that there's any
chance of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged disappointed failure
loss
pain discomfort any of those types of
potential feelings potential results
causes us to do what to put the brakes
on motivation the motive for the action
put the brakes on behavior the motor
cortex in the brain and then what do we
do
we then go do something else that we
feel is safer and easier for us
because
we already know what that behavior will
give us and usually we will move towards
something pleasurable something that's
common something that we've always done
i'm in this three year journey of trying
to conceive and
really for a year and a half almost two
years i was like in the low of it really
feeling like okay i'm not good enough my
body isn't working how can i make this
happen how can i make this happen right
and really pushing and controlling and
trying to eat things and
track my ovulation and all that crap
and then about the fall of 2017 i
started to get into more of a
surrendered state and i started
practicing the methods that i teach in
the book of just really
trusting that there
was
a
higher guidance that i believed in for
my whole life and relying on that and
that's when things started to get really
wild and synchronistic and so around the
fall of 2017 i was driving in the
countryside where i live most of the
time and this is where i do the majority
of my manifesting is just driving in the
car
looking at the foliage listening to my
mantra music and i feel so awesome when
i'm in that position and i'm just so
grateful in the moment and i'm driving
and i'm driving i'm like i feel so
awesome and so grateful that i live in
this country town i have all these
friends and i don't have any cell
service right now and i'm so psyched
about that and no one's bothering me and
i feel good and then all of a sudden i
felt the presence of a baby in the back
seat
and i was like
wow like deeply moved tears started to
roll down my face i felt so moved
and at that point i heard my intuition
say to me
the baby's coming in march
and i was like and it was so loud like
you know when you hear the voice of your
inspiration you're like that's it okay i
believe and so i started saying to
myself over and over like oh my god
march you know i have to conceive at
this time for the baby to come to work i
saw myself getting a little into it like
too into it and hooked into it so i said
okay listen you know what universe i'm
gonna give this over and if my baby is
indeed coming in march show me a sign
show me lily's to let me know that the
baby's coming in march
and a week later i got a letter in the
mail from a reader and it had this angel
card in it and on the back of it was
this picture of archangel gabriel and
archangel gabriel is typically depicted
holding lilies so i was like yo this is
dope and on the back he wrote
i thought that you needed this i was
like thank you good so here i am march
march is coming march is happening and
early march rolled around and i wasn't
pregnant so i was like what the hell and
not only was i devastated once again
another month has gone by i'm not
pregnant but this time i was like i
thought the universe had my back like i
was getting signs like what what's the
uh what's up
so i walked into my husband's office and
i was just hysterically crying so upset
so defeated
and at some my phone was like on the
desk like right here
and all of a sudden my phone started
playing a song
and the song was just repeating
repeating it so i go like you know when
your phone malfunctions you're like i'm
just gonna turn that off i was like okay
i'm just gonna turn it out and then i
look at the phone and i start listening
to the lyrics and the lyrics are way go
lily
way go lily and the guy keeps repeating
way go lily and then i look even further
and i look at the name of the song as
wade go lilly and he keeps repeating
lily and i look even further and the
album title is i see the sign
and where was this playing where what
area of your phone this was just my
phone just turned on oh wow no that's
you know it's spirit working through the
technology and so my phone just turned
on it was an album that i'd never heard
i'd never heard the song before it
wasn't in my spotify and it just began
playing now get this
so i get i april rolls around and i'm
pregnant
but then i did the math and i was like
when did i conceive
i conceived the last day of march
so that
synchronicity you know you hear march
you find your signs you feel super
guided that synchronicity is available
to all of us but it's when it had we
have to get out of that pusher mentality
and out of that controlling behavior to
allow the presence of spirit to work
through us and guide us and or the
universe or whatever you whatever you
call it to be the presence of of of
direction inspiration
to be that guide becoming a monk was my
biggest dream growing up from that time
period that i made the monk 18 which we
spoke about the last time i was here and
so that became like my identity from 18
to 22 and then 22 to 25 when i lived as
a monk so it's like that's been my
identity for seven years at least in my
heart in my head
and so when you get to the end of a
self-awareness journey which is actually
the beginning but you get to the end of
it because you're like oh i'm not a monk
anymore and i'm sure you've gone through
similar things like oh i'm not a ceo
anymore of this right of a business that
does this or someone else may go through
i'm not married anymore
i'm now divorced
i am now not single anymore or i'm not
uh alone i've got kids right it's like
we all go through these identity
transitions in our life
and to me
going from being a monk to not being a
monk was the hardest transition that i'd
been through at that time
and the question that i'm having is
i'm having reflections on who i truly am
and what my skills are what my strengths
are what my passion is what my
compassion is and i'm saying i want to
share all of this in like a cool way
through entertainment and i love movies
and that's what the book's full of like
pop culture references and it's it's a
it's it's who i am and what i love about
myself and then i'm going but this
doesn't align with what monk life is
meant to be in a sacred way
and that is like looking in the mirror
and going oh like i'm not comfortable
with that so when i share that with my
teacher and we're having this discussion
he's his advice and i think that's the
part that you're referring to he says to
me that
there's
students that come to university
and then they become professors
and there are students that come to the
university and then they go out and
become entrepreneurs
or go out and work and he says which do
you think are better
i'm like
i mean neither really like i can't
really choose what makes someone better
and he was just like that's the point
you you came here
some people stay at the monastery and go
on to become senior monks and teachers
and some people will go out and do what
they do outside and he goes but neither
is better and it was the simplest advice
it's one of those pieces of advice that
it's all about the person that says it
and not necessarily what you're hearing
but for me it just clarified the
judgment i had
the
attachment i had
that i could only be happy and
purposeful in this way
and that's really what we're all
struggling with that currently we all
have a projector screen up here that
goes this is what life's meant to look
like for it to be happy and then down
here we have the reality version of what
life actually looks like and we go oh no
they don't match that doesn't match
that's not working that means i'm going
in the wrong direction
the funny thing is the version you have
doesn't exist at all it's just an
imagination it's it's virtual reality
and the reality that you're experiencing
could actually be getting you closer to
that goal than you even think
but you just don't want to go down that
path because it doesn't look like the
one you imagine and that's where i was
at
i was having to go down a path that i
didn't imagine looked like success
but then the question is well what does
success look like then and it definitely
doesn't look like the version in your
head
so to me i started to realize and i
genuinely believe this and your
affirmation is very useful to me the
three years of my life
living as a monk were like being at
monk's school
and the last seven years have been the
exam
and everything in this book is stuff
that i've tried and tested in the last
seven years i learned it among school
but i tested it in in reality
and i'm only sharing what in the last
seven years it's perfectly worked for me
to feel like i'm exactly where i need to
be
that doesn't mean i don't have off days
that doesn't mean that i'm happy all the
time it doesn't mean that i don't get
angry it doesn't mean that i don't get
upset but i'm going in the direction
that i want to be going let me explain
what happened so this really interesting
concept called
ghosts in the nursery
and so trauma patterns get automated it
because they're not experienced in your
brain they're felt in your nervous
system
and so it's why you can have a pattern
from your past
but be completely unaware
that it's running your life right now
because it's stored not in your
conscious thought but in your nervous
system and you feel it in your body
before it even gets into your head and
so from there's this concept called
ghost in the nursery which basically
means there's all kinds of that goes on
when you're little that you may or may
not remember in your mind but your body
remembers it so for example if you had
parents that were just stressed out
and
they come home and they've been busy and
you're sitting there playing on the
floor and there's there's toys
everywhere and mom or dad's reaction to
a mess is to scream
that creates this kind of thing in your
nervous system now you may not remember
that episode that happened on may 17
1972
but your nervous system remembers what
it's like
so fast forward you're now 51 years old
and
you walk in the house and there's a mess
everywhere and even though you have said
i'm not going to bulldoze and yell at
anybody
my body recognizes the situation
so what do you do you repeat the pattern
you saw and so what i'm working on right
now is a pattern that is encoded in my
nervous system
i was trying to create a video yes or
two days ago
um for share the mic for share the mic
now i'm trying to create a video and i'm
like doing take after take because i
want to get it right
and my daughter comes waltzing into the
room
and was like
how long are you going to be doing this
and i was like
can't you say that i'm working i
literally like screamed at her and she
looked at me louis
and she goes
you have a real problem wow how's your
daughter
20.
and i said i i calmly said you're right
i do
when i get interrupted
i
lose control of the response and i'm
working so
hard and the way that you and i'm
clearly not mastering this yet but the
way that you do it is as you feel it
rise up
you have to you know you can use the
five second rule five four three two one
you can use just take a quick breath
you can notice the pattern and you've
got to create a pause between the
emotion rising up and the reaction that
gets automated and for many people the
reaction loses to run away
it's to leave the room it's to avoid the
confrontation the it was just easy you
know hold on let me let the clock go
even though you you hate being
interrupted by anything this is a great
interesting i did like i didn't do i
didn't do the bulldozer i was i was calm
because i wasn't a human being i'm only
mean to human beings um i know like i a
lot of people run away they avoid
conflict they say it's just easier
but if running away and avoiding
conflict
continues to create a pattern where you
feel invisible and your boundaries are
trumped on that's a pattern and you know
here's the other thing about patterns
running away
and being quiet might have saved you
when you were little
because if you were quiet and out of the
room you didn't get hit you didn't get
yelled at you were out of harm's way
so when you were little it was a genius
pattern because it protected you but the
issue for adults is that again we walk
around
with the patterns that we created when
we were eight years old in different
situations than we are in now and now we
are
completely a robot to these patterns
what is fear
is fear something that you should fear
no
i want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard
a light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air
air pressure maybe you're missing air or
water in your windshield wiper maybe the
back trunk door is open
isn't
the signal in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why
well when you understand how did this
organism
okay develop and how
does it keep us alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external world triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or destruction it causes you to do
what when there is a potential
that threat
predator or threat at the door
it lights up the fear signal sends
cortisol epinephrine or norepinephrine
into your bloodstream so you either know
how to fight it you run away or you
freeze hoping that the predator will go
away so when your brain
every brain
gets this signal
that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear
let's say there's a fear that you have a
failure and what it might mean to your
family what what about a fear of losing
money and not having enough to pay the
rent the mortgage or for retirement what
if there's a fear of trying something
and then it not working out and you're
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed or
rejected or judged oh my god if you
judge me then you're gonna reinforce my
low self-esteem of myself and then all i
should then who am i
you understand what's happening in the
circuits i'm just describing
so when our brain has
this fierce circuit activated do you
think the fear circuit causes you to go
oh hey let's take action anyway
or do you think it goes hi alert hi
alert hi alert be aware what's going on
what if you fail what if you succeed
what succeed and fail
whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself
it's a protection mechanism but here is
what i want you to remember
this automatic trigger and circuit
has been evolving for millions of years
but your specific experiences since you
were born in the modeling experiential
and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs
about things some empower you some
disempower let me give you an example
okay let me give you an example
when i say the word
or let me give you a different uh same
example with just a little different
story
if i say to you that i'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
god let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run
versus oh my god that would be great can
you take a picture of me with it so i
put on social media
so
is it really the snake
that is the threat
or is it
your concept
in your brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center
and for others the fear center same
stake stain stimuli there isn't even a
snake here i just add you think about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear
of being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
judged uh fear of disappointing
ourselves fear of failing if you're
succeeding there's 50 different types of
fears
we automatically trigger
the circuit
that does what stops our action taking
everyone has unresolved areas where they
are out of alignment due to their
upbringing their
belief systems from childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted
so some people might be health some
people might be sex some people it might
be money some people it might be their
worth some people might be all of the
above whatever we've all got it we've
all got an area or many where we are
misaligned with
the feeling of love and abundance and
and grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are doing anything wrong
it's that you are your awareness of it
is actually major okay
so the undoing of the lack mentality is
a journey of clearing the belief systems
from a experiential time in your life
right
that happens once again through books
like the universe has your back so
fantastic that you're doing that
transform fear to faith
excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural pathways
from the experiences that we've had as
children particularly young childhood
experiences but the good news is thanks
to
neuroplasticity our brain actually can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our ptsd can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new behavior so one thing that you can
do simply in this moment is to notice
when you are in that lac mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method i've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes i could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy which everyone i hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but
what you can do for yourself you're here
for self-help you're here for gabby to
tell me how i can serve myself
you can be in the proactive development
of new thought patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel step two forgive
yourself for having the thought it's
very simple up there's my childhood
story there's my parents lack story
again up there it is again all right i
forgive myself just showed up again
because that forgiveness will dissolve
that guilt and tension and fear that
you're manifesting it all that crap
right
third step
choose the next best feeling thought
choose the thought of you know what i
just forgave myself for that thought so
i'm dissolving it in this moment i
actually am listening to the universe
has your back and it's so supportive
then i can actually go and listen to
super attractor so you can go from
thought to thought to thought to reach
for the next best feeling thought so
your willingness to face this lack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you
right and especially if you're feeling
afraid that you're manifesting things
because you're having the thoughts then
just forgive the thoughts because or
forgive yourself for having the thought
because the moment that you say oh i
forgive myself for that thought or i
forgive that thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized i am not that
thought it's just a thought that i keep
thinking i am not that belief it's just
a thought that i keep thinking the
beautiful thing about monk life is half
the day is self and half the day is
service that's how you're taught to live
okay so the morning hours are for you to
fill yourself it's almost like putting
on mental emotional and physical armor
like that's what a morning routine is
our days are tiring our days are busy
our days are draining
well guess what if you didn't put your
armor on in the morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded i come back home feeling
wounded sometimes but guess what if you
put your armor on in the morning a
warrior would never go out onto a
battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are
warriors in one sense
and so without wearing that so for me a
morning routine is putting on emotional
armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut
you're protected
and i know that when my morning routine
is at its best i feel protected
whereas when my morning routine is
weakened i feel weak
and so for me the morning routine as i
get strategic about it there's two
principles you have to know
location has energy
and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day
that place now
holds that energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and i'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when i meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
south india
it was easier to meditate because people
have been meditating there for thousands
of years
and so when you find a space in your
home and even if you've got like i lived
in a 500 square foot apartment in new
york
four years ago and i just had a tiny
corner which i dedicated to my sacred
practices so if you you don't have to
have a big home to do this you don't
have to be wealthy to do this you can
find just a corner in your home that you
dedicate your meditation space or your
reflection space so first thing location
has energy second thing
time has memory
and this is something that people
underestimate when you do something at
the same time every day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day
generally we feel hungry at the same
time most people if you've got a
regulated diet you'll feel hungry you
will feel tired at the same time every
day you will look towards that coke can
or that sugar or that chocolate bar at
the same time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what i recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and i call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e
t stands for thankfulness
there needs to be
even if it's five minutes five minutes
of thankfulness of gratitude every
single morning and that has to be
gratitude that's specific it can't be
gratitude that's generic so generic
gratitude is something that anyone could
be grateful for oh i'm grateful for the
sky i'm grateful for air i'm grateful
for water that's cool but it's generic
gratitude
specific gratitude is i'm grateful for
the fact that i have someone calling me
this morning i'm grateful for the fact
that i can still call my parents i'm
grateful for the fact that i have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact i'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is insight i think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which i
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcasts books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table i
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and i
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you pick up one line it will impact
you and it'll speak to you so insight
you need insight every day m is
meditation and i believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice i give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than i can i exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
one-on-one with the iceman wim hof check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i'm a normal guy
simple guy but i'm gonna change the
world
i lost my wife in 95
was alone with four children no money
the only thing i